a traveler comes upon the statue of an emperor
inscribed with the words my name is azamendius
king of kings look upon my works and despair only
there's nothing left beside it except empty desert
it is good to be back i really wish
they'd let us play music up here
why because we'd already be on our feet ready
for action we have considered your request
for passage through our territory and we will
not stop you but do not expect us to save you
pursuing exploration always carries risk
i say we risk it everything forbidden is
sweet this is a good day it is a good day you
do know where you're going right nope oh boy
let's go make some history i didn't
prepare anything just speak from your heart
we're about to enter unexplored space i know
you're all just as excited as i am so let's give
this everything we got and may the force be with
you how was that perfect we've served together
we've laughed together and we all owe each other
our lives you will surrender or you will die
and it's a very special thing we should all
get big bonuses this is history in the making
here's to a better future
i will be sure to bring my
what does lieutenant malloy call
it my a-game there you go buddy
we have to find a way to
preserve some kind of peace
humans have a tendency to reduce
things to black and white good and evil
we can find a way to coexist you're kaylon
your people would like to see us all dead
after all these years you're still able to
surprise me show the galaxy that humans are
different that we value life even when our
enemies don't captain you are being deceived
it's almost like yesterday was one life
and today's another
and everything's different on this side of time
definitely worth the wait
you